next question today is from RJ RJ says
hey David how can we combat statements
like black people are brainwashed by the
Democrats from the right okay so this
there's a lot tied up in this question
if you have not heard that statement
before that's great
I wish I had also never heard it but the
idea of the brainwashing of voting
groups implies that you have a group of
people an identity group that votes for
one party or the other despite the fact
that they would actually be better off
by supporting the other party based on
the policy right so like with black
voters what the Republicans have been
claiming is black voters have been
brainwashed into voting for Democrats
even though they would be better off by
supporting Republicans because you have
to demonstrate that otherwise black
people are just voting for Democrats
because the policies of Democrats could
be or are better for black people which
I believe is actually the case so to
start examining this the first question
you have to ask is okay on which issue
is the Republican policy better overall
for black Americans than the Democratic
policy and I can't think of any such
policy you will hear people from the
right who say that affirmative action is
actually bad for minorities because it
is an example of the bigotry of saw of
low expectations the soft bigotry of low
expectations is the way they like to
describe it I believe that there is no
factual case to be made that that has
been the impact of affirmative action in
places where it exists and remembered
that in most places affirmative action
does not actually exist in the way that
is described by the right so unless you
can actually sit link some specific
policies of the rights with lack of
support for Republicans by black people
the even mere claim on its face that
black people have been quote brainwashed
by Democrats Falls pretty flat now in
fact when you think about it there's a
much stronger case to be made that poor
and lower middle class right-wingers are
the ones who have been brain
washed by the Republican Party and I
think back to the Tea Party in 2010 you
had people who statistically will never
be rich
statistically will never earn two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year which I think was the tax bracket
sort of in question at the time that the
Tea Party really wanted to lower the
marginal tax rate on saying we support
the Tea Party despite the fact that the
policies would be great for rich people
and not good for lower and lower middle
class and even middle class Americans so
if you want to see political
brainwashing it's all the people on the
right that insist on voting Republicans
against their own best interests now let
me go to a counter example to the black
people are brainwashed by Democrats meme
when California had a referendum vote
called Proposition 8 around gay marriage
which was widely supported by Democrats
you didn't see black people come out in
droves to support gay marriage in
California so it's almost like black
people can understand that on most
issues Democrats actually have the right
slate of policies to improve their
circumstances but they're not just going
to go out and vote for gay marriage
merely because Democrats wanted the
black population at the time and still
to some degree has more skepticism of
gay marriage and homophobia within
within its borders and that was very
much reflected in Proposition 8 mostly
they vote with Democrats but they broke
with many Democrats on that particular
issue I I do want to point out also
there's a bit of an implicit racism in
saying that because Republicans are very
United as a voting bloc nationally they
are brainwashed but that same standard
is not applied to other groups I'll give
you an example Jews in the United States
are very liberal Jews vote depending on
the election seventy-five to eighty
percent with Democrats with the more
liberal candidate with the more
progressive candidate whatever if
anything you hear the opposite which is
that Jew
brainwashed by the pro-israeli antics of
the right well if they are it seems to
have failed or confuse them because
they're almost exclusively voting for
Democrats but you don't really hear that
word applied so my instinct Pat is that
there is some implicit racism in saying
that the United voting bloc not
completely but significantly if black
people is a brainwashing but it's not
applied to other groups and might I add
if you're a Republican strategist and
you're trying to pick off some
african-american voters and persuade
them to vote with your side it's a
really bad idea to be condescending and
start saying that they're brainwashed
like that's that's not going to work out
for you
no I completely agree with you
and then there's also the issue of sort
of conservatism pushing individualism in
many ways and black Americans like many
other groups have a strong group
identity which goes beyond policy and it
would be another reason to favor
generally collectivist policies and in
the United States to the extent that
there is a difference between Democrats
and Republicans on that Democrats are
the ones advocating for the more
collectivist policies than Republicans
and that would be a very specific
political reason why you would see black
Americans support Democrats more than
Republicans so there's really simply no
evidence for this brainwashing that the
right claims exists